the Joe Rogan experience Amanda Nunez is
a freak she's a monster freak she should
be put in jail though she's done he's
playin well cyborg you can see cyborg
going what the yeah yeah cuz like I said
doesn't look like she hits that high oh
my gosh and then it lands it's just like
whoa like yes she's got something going
on like she's crazy how some people just
have this weird power and it got that
touch and yeah like Deontay Wilder he's
the best example of it's like what the
[ __ ] we let Alex Pereira you know Alex
Pereira and Rory he's the only guy
that's knocked out Israel at the Sonya
knocked a mountain kickboxing fight he's
a [ __ ] freak it's the same thing
punch he knocked him out with a left
hook yeah one punch boom flatlined oh
yeah he hits so [ __ ] hard he knocks
out everybody it's one of those weird
guys where you know sometimes people
just have this power
yes weird freaky power yeah and I'm
still hopeful that like that's gonna be
me eventually because like you know
Amanda Nunez didn't really do that for a
long time and then after that catfight I
think after the shevchenko the first
schevchenko fight
she just started finding her groove and
finding that money mark and then just
really took her training far more
seriously and invested much more time in
a strength and conditioning okay that's
a big factor because the man who we get
tired and that's what happened in the
cat Zingano fight yeah it's in got she
had cat Zingano really badly hurt in the
first round but then cat just so tough
she came back in a second and when I'm
stopping her I think that's why that's
why the rematch happen because Valentina
just had a really strong last round but
it's interesting how like you need
weight classes you need those increments
because Valentina 125 is just a [ __ ]
monster yeah she's a monster yeah
she's so good it's such a huge gap to
get such a huge gap between like and a
number one contender and
champ doesn't make sense it's crazy that
fight I did my best to pump up Caitlin
chick egg in and to make it seem like
it's gonna be a good fight but all I
could think of is like how is this girl
gonna beat her yeah how are you gonna
beat her well is everything perfect yeah
I thought like numbers like if you're
going just like volume you know I
thought that Caitlin could like you know
close the gap a bit
I didn't think so this is why because
Caitlin she uses points she scores well
but she very rarely knocks people out
like she knocked down Liz Carmouche with
a head kick right Liz survived and one
that win in the decision right you like
Valentina makes you pay she makes you
pay so like all those like shots that
she would throw the volume it's
different because there's he put the
shots out there and then back and it
comes back at you just like whoa those
those kicks come back even you like [ __ ]
yeah elbow comes back and you're like
whoa so now you're like now everything's
more at a distance and you you lose your
ability to engage you get nervous
because every time you engage she's
looking to take especially after that
Jessica I fight oh yeah whoa yeah that
was crazy
I think that's the one that made me a
fan because I was hating for a while she
just has a funny way yes she beat up
that poor girl that girl I think she's
fighting is is she don't know she's not
fighting in Auckland right I do not know
no she's on their car but I don't
remember they should have stopped that
fight way does just mean but like after
that I was just like man yeah like
giving her all these props for
destroying this poor girl and like she
shouldn't have been in there against
anyone but then after the Jessica I
fight I was like yo she's got something
like she's scared she's a dominant yeah
she's gonna be a dominant champ she's
just a scary person
she went down to the range in Texas and
the guys who run the range were like the
way that lady shoots she shoots like a
[ __ ] Special Ops soldier we haven't
seen someone come in here and shoot that
good unless they're a seal or a
competitive
oh my god she's a [ __ ] straight-up
killer all around someone stop talking
[ __ ] about I dance yeah they're like
yeah you guys see her groups like the
group shoes like pistol groups like
everything's in the she's she's she's a
special hard lady you should take her
hunting with you oh she probably would
[ __ ] jump on something's back and
strangler
[Applause]